>>> WE COME TO THIS PLACE FOR
MAGIC.
WE COME TO AMC THEATERS TO
LAUGH, TO CRY, TO CARE.
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT, ALL OF US.
THAT INDESCRIBABLE FEELING WE
GET WHEN THE LIGHTS BEGIN TO
DIM.
OH, I CAN'T DESCRIBE IT.
AND WE GO PLACES WE'VE NEVER
BEEN BEFORE, NOT JUST ENTERTAIN,
BUT SOMEHOW REBORN TOGETHER.
DAZZLING IMAMGS ON A HUGE SILVER
SCREEN.
SOMEHOW HEART BREAK FEELS GOOD
IN A PLACE LIKE THIS.
>> HEARTBREAK FEELS GOOD IN A
PLACE LIKE THIS.
HEARTBREAK FEELS GOOD IN A PLACE
LIKE THIS.
>> AND I CAN FEEL.
OUR HEROES FEEL LIKE THE BEST
PART OF US, AND OUR STORIES FEEL
PERFECT.
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> WE ARE HERE!
AMC, WE MAKE MOVIES BETTER.
>> WHAT THE [ BLEEP ] JUST
HAPPENED?